Lord, right. On behalf of Trinity Belicham, I was going to say thank you so much for your generous hospitality to us both today and also your coming offer us to begin using your building here coming soon.
So we really do appreciate it. We deeply appreciate you and our thrilled department with you from the Second Gospel here in Oldendale and beyond.
If you've got a Bible, please turn with me to 2nd Corinthians chapter 13. It's the book of sector it is right there at the end of book chapter 13.
That Trinity we've just finished going through the book of Exodus together. So I had a plan to speak on in 1st chapter 13 and 14 which is where the spies are sent into the land, the spy of Amal Fuzz.
I didn't want to give the wrong impression this morning. So please turn to sector 13 instead. All trip we decide we are we are all pilgrims together on the way to the Olden at Promsley.
This morning we looked at a short passage shows us what that line is together. Lewis liked.
2nd Corinthians 13 beginning of verse five.
Thank you for this wonderful opportunity that you've given us.
Gather this morning as your family around your world.
So we're at the fire spirit. You would open our arms to see wonders things show us more of Jesus.
Maybe we changed.
This morning we are at the beginning of the beginning of the end as it were.
So you've got the end of the book and here we are at our first time kind of gathering together.
So what's going on here in 2nd Corinthians? The Apostle Paul has written this letter and now he's drawn this letter through for a close.
And he has this kind of final goodbye. And this final goodbye that he says in the book is packed full of meaning.
I don't know if you realize that our word in English for goodbye is also packed full of meaning.
If you go back to where it comes from it actually comes from four words that kind of got squished together.
You know those four words are? Four words are God be with you.
So over time that phrase as it was said kind of got constrained into what we now say which is a goodbye.
It's a short version of that. And gone being with you is really a good summary of what Apostle Paul is writing in the 2nd Corinthians.
As he says goodbye this is as far as the letter goes to the church there.
When you look at how he begins in this section that we're looking at he gives a set of instructions about how they are to interact with one another as in church.
He then gives a radius from the wider church and then he moves on most importantly when we talk about what God is doing in there as the church.
Twice he speaks of God being with them and he connects God with them to their life together as a church body.
So what I want us to see this morning is simply this that our life together as the church flows from the very line of God himself.
And then this hits presents that shapes the church into being the people that he calls us to be together.
My prayer if they would experience this we would know this presence with us not only in our individual congregations but also in our interaction with one another as congregations.
So the way we're going to look at this this morning is by considering just two simple things.
First of all we're going to see the God who brought them together and then we're going to see the life together that he calls us to.
With God who brings us together what's this like move on that he calls us to.
So Paul here speaks about God as the God of love and peace being with them.
You see that in chapter 15 verse 11 and then when you get to verse 14 you have this wonderful beautiful trans-arean blessing.
The grace of the Lord Jesus Christ the love of God and fellowship of the Holy Spirit be with you all.
So who is this guy who has brought us together?
First of all he's the triune God.
In fact if you're following the church calendar closely I noticed it was at the front of the bulletin today.
Today is Trinity Sunday and this is who our God is he is triune.
So what does it mean when we talk about how he's being triune?
What do we mean when we say the Trinity?
When we look across the whole of scripture you see that it teaches that there is one God who exists eternally in three versions father, son, and Holy Spirit.
And in our passage we see the one God being spoken of and yet we also see the three mercenaries in God.
You've got the three versions into one verse here in verse 14.
So while the Trinity is something that is beyond our comprehension let me say it's not a problem to be solved.
It is rather a mystery to delight in.
This is who our God, the God who is with us has revealed himself to be.
And God is trying to increase the Trinity.
That also means that he has a relational goal.
You see the Trinity isn't just some abstract theological concept.
It's a way of expressing the perfection that exists between the persons of God.
You see before anything existed, perfect love, the perfect peace was there.
It is there in the shared life of the Trinity.
A lot of times C.S. Lewis is from him.
He described his relationship within God as the ray of the dance.
He said something pretty remarkable about this dance.
Let me read to you what he says in the New York Christianity book.
He said the whole dance or drama or pattern of this three personal life is played out in each one of us.
But he did it another way around each one of us has got to enter that pattern to take his place in the dance.
I want to hear what he's saying there.
You see this dance, this shared life of the life in the Trinity is something that God is inviting us to enter.
This is not just found in Lewis. This is found across the whole of scripture.
You see when God created us, he created us in his image.
One aspect of what that means is the fact that we too are created as relational beings.
So this God exists eternally as Father, Son and Holy Spirit creates us in his image.
That we might know him, that we might be in relationship with him and with one another as well.
This God invites us to know him as our receiving joy.
We were made, we might know God and enjoy him forever, but life is wrong.
And that column is sin. Sin separates us from God.
Instead of enjoying this life with God that we were made for, we are instead dead in our sins.
So how is this relationship restored? How should we enter this life with God?
Well, God is the one who takes age. He is the one who comes to us to bring us to himself.
And each member of the Trinity is involved.
This is on the verse 14. The grace of the Lord Jesus Christ is involved.
God's grace is giving nature. This is God giving us what we do not deserve.
This is especially seen in the Lord Jesus.
Look, I'll say it in Corinthians chapter 8, it speaks about it in verse 9.
It says,
This isn't speaking about comparatively rich as he is.
It's saying that all of the riches of heaven's glory belong to Jesus,
but He willingly laid a design and He became a man.
He took our sin upon himself. He died in our place.
This is how gracious he is. He is willing to give himself for us.
Why?
So we by faith might receive the riches of this grace.
Though we mind the reminiscence to God,
clothed in the righteousness of Jesus,
and brought into eternal relationship of love with the God who reigns in Him in worship.
You see, it's through Jesus that we also come to see the love of God.
So we get the grace of Jesus and the love of God.
So it isn't that Jesus is the gracious member of the Trinity,
but really God really all is punished.
Jesus comes and you're being...it's not that.
Rather, Jesus has shown us the great love of the Father for us.
So you look at Romans chapter 5 and verse 8.
It says,
Christ died for us.
For God so loved the world, as it says in chapter 16,
that He dated His only Son.
So when we look at it cross the prize, we see the love of God at the school.
Lost the fellowship of the Holy Spirit is involved.
The Spirit is God with us,
applying the Word of Christ in our lives.
He brings us into this fellowship with God through the Word of Christ.
And when that happens, He even takes up the residence in us.
This is God preaching us into a relationship with Himself.
This is what the fellowship is.
And this is just as real as the fellowship that the disciples enjoyed with Jesus
when they walked on earth with Him.
You read this in 1 John 1 and verse 3.
Hear what people on Jesus' disciples said.
He said,
That which we have seen and heard, we proclaim also to you
that you too may have fellowship with us.
And indeed our fellowship is with the Father,
with His Son Jesus Christ.
We're invited into the same fellowship.
But it doesn't stop there.
God advises us into a relationship with Himself.
So He also brings us into a relationship with one other.
You see that being expressed throughout Scripture
in the preaching of the family of Adam and Eve.
You see that in the nation of Israel.
Now you see this in the life of the Church.
You see it is God's presence with us
that transforms us into a people
who reflect His life in the world around us.
In other words, the life that we share together
in the life of the Church
flows from the very together life of God.
And we unite as a together in Coliseum.
What's that look like in practice?
So we're going to see that second day.
So why does this together life look like?
Well when you look at the Church of the Corinth.
You see that our life together is pretty messy.
It's all across both letters.
We have in Scripture 1 and 2 Corinthians.
Kind of the mess that was there.
But the good news is that they were in the hands of someone
that's creating something beautiful.
And the same thing is true of us as well through the process.
Recently I've taken an interest in
this Southern self-taught folk artist called Howard Finster.
He's had this creature for many years.
He's a pretty quirky guy.
And when he was 15 or 59 years old, rather,
he decided that one way he could get his message across
was through increasing art.
So he produced thousands of works of art.
And one of the things that he did is he decided
he was going to create something called Paradise Garden.
It's in Northwest Georgia.
This is it today.
He got to work on Paradise Garden.
And one that he was known for doing was taking old bits of junk.
And he was using all these different materials
to create something beautiful out of it.
So if a neighbor has old articles
they didn't know what to do with it.
They brought it to Howard for some old rusty bikes
that he'd created in this work of art.
This tower that's there at Paradise Garden.
So he was taking all these different broken pieces.
He's even disstarting items.
His hands is creating something beautiful.
It's there in the midst.
That's not a fan description of the church.
See, God takes different people from all kinds of backgrounds,
cultures, personalities, ages.
You could go on with all kinds of descriptions of differences.
And yet he unites us together as one in a crust.
The fact is he is at work in our midst.
He takes us as broken people.
And he shapes us into the people who glorifies him with our life together.
So Paul writes here,
I want us to what God is doing in their midst
to help them to live out his collective calling as the people of dawn.
Even as he tells us what they should be doing
he makes it clear this is coming from who they are together in Christ.
So that was what he says about who they are in Christ.
We're settled to see.
That's how he addresses me.
He says in verse 11,
Finally brothers or brothers and sisters.
So he is addressing them as family.
That's who they are.
To be in Christ is to be long to the family of God.
Through Christ we come to know God as our Father
but it doesn't stop there with our individual relationship with God.
We have brothers and sisters.
We have siblings.
This is a big family.
We're not just family in a kind of closer to what,
but you get a new job and the boss says,
hey what about corporation man?
We'll be your family.
I don't even remember her down before.
It's actually the same that we're family is to speak of a spiritual reality
that is as real as our flesh and blood relationship with our perfect family.
The thing about this relationship with David Delvin is it lasts forever.
Most of us are meeting new people here for the first time today and that's wonderful.
We know this as you do that our relationship runs deeper than perhaps the first real ones.
Some of those TV shows where people praise their ancestry and do I have any relatives?
You know you're still living in the area and all of a sudden they realize
that actually they do have a relative and they need a relative.
Often there's tears.
They go and just snap and there's a relationship that runs far into you even than they realize.
That's what's happening today.
We need to deal for the first time and yet we are part of the same family.
Can you understand another word following it is for the church?
It's not spoken of but the church core is directly but it avances much to them.
That's what he says in verse 13.
He says, all the saints are breathing.
He's given them a warm breathing from the churches that he has been with
and he refers to them as the saints and say his term for verse of
they set art in God's holy people.
You might remember this is applied in church of Corinth too.
If you look back in chapter 12 and verse 20 he says,
well I fear that when I come to you there's one being quarreling, jealousy, anger, hostility, slander,
gossip, conceit, disorder.
Now he's actually sending behavior and yet if they are in promise they too, Marcell.
By the first grant he's chapter one, verse two, Paul wrote to them as those who were sanctified into Christ
and called the saints together with all those who call upon the name of the Lord.
So what makes a person a saint isn't the fact that totally in God and their acts together.
It is in Christ that we are said part, cloaked in his righteousness and called God's holy people.
But of course the challenge now is to live as Catholic people.
This is what God is doing in our midst.
He's helping us to live as a family of God and to live alive of the holiness.
See this is where he gets to how he addresses in terms of how we live together.
See church is not nearly an event that we attend as individuals.
I know there's a tendency in many places, returns to be treated in that way.
Church is a community that we respect and together.
We're called to reflect the lightness of Jesus in our care one for another.
Individuals.
The glory of the trying God is seen out of the quantity of people that attend to the truth.
The quality of the relationships.
That's the question.
So what does that look like for actually?
Well I'm going to just breeze through six things.
That was like 19.
First of all, what is a joyful human?
He says finally brothers rejoice.
The fact is that God's presence is the one that is forming this community.
In his presence it says in Psalm 1611 there is fullness of joy.
At this right end there are pleasures ever more.
If this presence is so central to what kind of atmosphere that produce.
A joyful one.
And that isn't being keeping us superficial Sunday smile hey when you need it.
The fact is there are some real sorrows that we share together this side of eternity.
But at the same time there's indeed well of joy in our life.
This is why Paul will say in 7th and 8th, 6th and 10th, at least sorrowful yet all of us propose to be true at the same time.
So how did he get to this life of joy?
Well there's a road to God of all because the second characteristic is it's an imperfect community.
You know there's a better belief here and there.
He says to them aim for restoration of all that is about what it looks like to be in community with one another.
The ways of joy often means walking the difficult road of restoration.
So word restoration here by the way, I'm curious to know if you have anything that is broken.
If you go back to the Gospels you see this is word that was used to people mending their fishing nets.
Or sometimes they get broken and they need to be mended.
So in the Church of Cori there are sharp words and counsel and slander.
That is going to cause damage to relationships for sure.
But here we see that by the grace of God, this is not the young payer.
It's not the young pending.
He is able to restore those relationships.
The fact is that if you have a sense of shame with somebody in the church
it can be easier to just avoid that person.
The hard and humbling word of mending that relationship.
This is what the Lord calls us to.
The Lord is drawing us continually towards one another in love.
He calls us to that hard and humbling word to examine our own self
and things we may have gotten wrong.
To confess our sins to one another.
To extend forgiveness to one another.
We're in the dead-experiment perfect community.
Probably in the eukaryaginus community.
He says this, comfort one another.
Word comfort essentially means encourage.
Encourage.
This is an invitation not only to deal with a kind of negative relational strife
that might exist, but to possibly come alongside one another.
To encourage one another in the court.
To help us to follow Christ together.
This is two ways free.
This is acknowledging that you've got room to grow
and that you need others within the life of the church.
And it's also looking for an opportunity to come alongside them
and encourage them to their role.
So where does that lead to a working united community?
Agree with one another.
Live in peace.
You see a church that seeks to mend relationships
and refer to one another in the Lord.
And did church fall through tears?
I mean, tell us that I agreed with one another.
He's talking about one-supmon.
This was a church that was marked by constant disagreements
and factions throwing around those disagreements.
He's calling the now community.
But he's not calling them, by the way, to agree about every committee,
but that of my new shallow, of every single decision.
Rather to live in one accord.
To be determined to be united by the things that matter most.
To live together under the enforcement of God's word.
The united's veteran, the unity of the spirit
along with peace as he set them peace.
There's another thing that is in the bud and communes.
It's the 15th.
See the verse 12 and reads one another in the holy case.
It says right there, it's in the Bible.
So turn to your name.
This was a cultural form of agreeing at a time.
You're still both today to agree one another in this way.
There's nothing off about this.
We're whole. This is a holy case to you.
So what do we learn from here?
It's this.
Christian unity isn't just an idea.
It is something that is combined.
It could take the form of the offer of a holy handshake
to someone you've not acted for.
It could take the form of a meal brought to the door
of someone in need.
It could take the form of offering a physical space
to a church in need.
It is combining the very self-giving love.
And our relationship is one with another.
And the last thing, sixthly, is that in God's center of being.
What we were looking at was the vaccines together at Trinity.
The last place we arrived was the tower in Echel.
There we saw that God's glorious presence
well with His people.
And it was right in the center of their in camp.
God was right on the center of their in the line to get them.
And God was at the center of our online together.
And sharing in this kind of life together is at the stick God is truly
the less so you see that in the universal at least do these things and the God of
love and peace will be missed by the way it doesn't say do these things then the
love God the God of love and peace will be with the spirit doing these things
and then the God of love and peace will be with them in other words is a very
love and peace of a shining God that we are experiencing when we live together in
these ways. In other words, life follows us too as it comes from us. It comes
ultimately from him. That's why this all leads to that beautiful
editition that we need because this is the grace of the Lord Jesus. It creates
the grace of the Lord. It's the love of God coming here in our expressions of
love to one another. It is the fellowship of the Holy Spirit that draws together
this great needs for God, what one under the same person and this is this is my
prayer for both of our human catches and as we interact one with another we
will not just occupy a shared space. We also enjoy a shared life of life
for a lot of things.
Some may be very slow to respond to people are felt in the fellowship
of the Holy Spirit.